my brother
my brother's six years older so
we're raised together
he's slowly gaining weight his wife
adopts our diet comes in and fast
overcomes her own health issues he's on
a vegan program 15 years later my
brother's still eating chicken and doing
stuff and getting fatter and he's got he
can't play volleyball anymore his legs
are all swollen up you know i'm poking
him but he won't do anything finally he
calls me from the hospital
he says alan i'm in the hospital
i had a heart attack so he said oh they
want to do a quadruple bypass and i said
well talk to your surgeon he asked the
surgeon he says
if you do a bypass won't they plug up
again
yeah eventually but you know last longer
than stenson he says what if i made
radical diet and lifestyle change he
said the surgeon laughed at him
he said mark you're not gonna make time
lifestyle changes come on
checked himself out
got on a whole plant food sos free diet
lost the 50 pounds back to playing
volleyball past his stress test still
has his vessels